but crisps for these purposes as we look
at what the teams in the AFC North need
let's assume the Bengals are gonna take
Joe borough number one so let's set
aside the quarterback position the
bengals otherwise cannot leave the 2020
draft without what yeah I mean the
Bengals have a lot of holes to fill we
know that to me it's between offensive
linemen or linebacker and I would say
more than anything
probably offensive linemen you know
they've done some good things as far as
their interior part of their offense you
know the last few years as far as
drafting guys center guard doing things
like that they need to improve tackle
play that's probably the thing that
concerns me the most about their roster
and if you're gonna take Joe borough at
number one and you want his career to
last and him to be healthy you know
that's the proper thing to do I think
and I think that's a move you could see
them make maybe at the top of the second
round Mike is get that tackle that they
feel could be the linchpin and the
protector for Joe Burrell but yeah Joe
burrow Mike the the thing I'll just say
just to hit on that because obviously I
would quarterback would be the number
one thing I would say but it's too
obvious here burrow is special in my
opinion in a lot of ways he really
reminds me of Peyton Manning he really
does you know just the way he plays it's
not the biggest arm you've ever seen but
it's still very good the accuracy is
through the roof and the plays he makes
with in the pocket with people around
him it's just special but I think other
than that quarterback yes I would want
to see it often to tackle specifically
and he is the rare case of a college
quarterback who did it all in one year
usually we see that number one overall
pick coming we have him pegged going
into his final year of college football
that he's the guy who's gonna be at the
top of the stack the following April and
for Bravo went from largely unknown to
Heisman Trophy winner 15 and no team and
now the unquestioned best player in the
draft or at least best quarterback Chase
young would argue with him persuasively
as to who the best overall player is
right I think the Bengals need a knee
they need a receiver
John Ross has been a disappointment he
can't stay healthy and AJ Green is not
going to be there next year they may
keep him all of 2020 but they're not
going to keep him beyond this season
they typically don't keep guys after
they franchise tagged and they have a
hard time taking that franchise tag and
promise of a 20% raise the following
year and turning it into a long-term
deal they need to bolster the position
they've got Joe Mixon it running back
they're gonna have Joe burrow
quarterback they need an receiver
preferably somebody named Joe who can
can catch passes and get that that that
offense fully functioning the way that
it needs to I agree with you the neat
offensive lineman because you can't do
anything if you don't have somebody
blocking but I'm just not impressed with
their core of pass catchers especially
now the tire Tyler Eifert finally moves
on in free agency he had the potential
to be a great tight end injuries were an
issue for him they just got to keep
their guys healthy right Chris at some
point you got so many injuries to your
receivers in your tight ends is it just
bad lockers or something else going on
if I'm the Bengals I spend a little bit
of money to try to figure out if there's
something else going on well yeah I mean
it's definitely been an issue you know
you're right with John Ross but this was
an issue that people were worried about
with John Ross you know coming out of
college that this could be a problem for
his career and then AJ Green listen I
think that was just an unfortunate and
an injury I think he'll be okay and good
to go from here on out but you know I
hear you you know with my Tyler voice
well dr. Sims chiming in despite having
no medical knowledge or training and no
assessment of AJ Green says he'll be
fine from here on out well I'm just
going by talking about an injury that
I've seen a lot of people come back from
over time to heal I know you're just
being a jerk and that's what you're good
at but yeah yeah I hear you with the
wide receiver thing I would think that's
something that certainly think about
some of the second third fourth round
Mike Steelers can't leave the draft
without what Chris you know Mike I want
to say the same thing with the Steelers
you know you look at their offensive
line they're getting up there in age I
mean whether it's Pouncy the tackle
position would you know Ramon Foster
retired last year so I really think
that's a position you look at their team
it is you know a little longer the tooth
and they need to infuse some young
talent there you know defensively
they're really in a good position
they're very talented you know maybe
they could add a corner to the fold but
but I look at their offense more than
anything you know Mike I would go either
that or the the the discussion would be
for a running back you know I think
that's all
in the in the fold - James Conner has
not been the greatest levy on valve
replacement he's had injury issues - you
know so you know the more I talk about
it and sit here I want to say running
back they needed they need a difference
making running back okay I'm changing my
offensive line pick in the back room
I'm sorry the second round I'm going
Steelers running back to give their
offense another weapon and I'm gonna say
that just like the team on the other
side of the Commonwealth of Pennsylvania
they need a receiver that can stretch
the field we saw last year now look Ben
Roethlisberger was injured most of the
season but when you don't have an
Antonio Brown who can take the top off
the defense open up the rest of the
offense it becomes a lot harder for your
running backs to do anything it becomes
harder for juju Smith Schuster to get
open
juju Smith Schuster is not the guy
that's gonna stretch the field in fact
I've already seen some talk that he's
not gonna get a second contract in
Pittsburgh which will upset a lot of
Steeler fans or at a minimum they're not
gonna pay huge money to keep juju around
you gotta have all the tools to be a
highly paid receiver and one of the
tools is the ability to run really fast
and force safeties to follow you along
with the cornerback that they've
assigned to cover you that's what the
Steelers desperately need and they do a
very good job of finding great receivers
in the mid to late rounds Kevin Kolbert
needs to do that this year maybe that's
one of the reasons why Kolbert wants
three more rounds
he'll just draft three more receivers
rounds eight nine ten and they'll
probably all end up being great
receivers because that's one of the
things that he's very good at the Browns
can't you the draft without what Chris
it's two positions that jump out again
it's back to the offensive line tackle
position conversation I mean it's funny
we're saying this for the AFC North or
linebacker I look at but I think more
than anything you know I'm looking at
offensive tackle to be the position they
need to leave the draft with the most
you know I'm not saying that's what
they'll take it number ten in the first
round I do think that there'll be a top
end left tackle to be had there at that
pick if they want to do that but you
know if there was a linebacker that was
in their fancy to which I don't know if
there's anybody really in that
conversation for a top ten top 12 pick
at the linebacker position
other than Isaiah Simmons from Clemson
and I'm not sure he'd be there by 10 so
Mike I'm gonna say more than anything
for their team they need the offensive
tackle yeah but they've still been
looking for that left tack what a really
nail down since Joe tonight they spent
the money they spent the money on Jack
Conklin from the Tennessee Titans which
was impressive but but you're look
you're right they need to give Baker
Mayfield every opportunity to be
successful and I know it's not sexy to
take offensive lineman in the draft you
want players are gonna be generating
fantasy stats and selling jerseys and
whatnot but you want to boost the guys
that you have and one way to do that
improve your blocking all right one
thing I just say you're right though
Mike I mean if you want Nick chaga Baker
Mayfield and and and Jarvis Landry and
Odell Beckham jr. to get off you know
you need those type of players and yeah
I just think that's pretty much a
desperate need for their team sorry to
cut you off that's all right Ravens
can't leave the draft without what you
know the Ravens have a lot of I would
say an edge pass rusher that would be
the thing that jumps out to me more than
anything the linebacker position in
general is a need for them you know
offensively hey look at them ago could
they use a receiver you know sure maybe
another guy to the mix but I don't think
it's anything desperate they're you know
safety position Earl Thomas getting up
there an age that's in the conversation
but with losing za'darius Smith and CJ
Mosley the year before that and now
having to franchise tag of Matthew Jude
on you know something in the linebacker
conversation would make sense to me for
the Baltimore Ravens whether that's an
edge guy or a true stand up middle
linebacker it is a linebacker
nonetheless that I think the Baltimore
Ravens need more than anything see and I
think with Marshall Yonder retiring and
that offensive line is such a critical
component to keeping Lamar Jackson
healthy and running that unique offense
that was designed specifically to suit
Jackson's skills you need offensive
lineman who can move who can block who
can maybe provide that last little chip
to a guy who are bearing down on Lamar
Jackson so I think they need to focus on
protecting Lamar Jackson at all cost
because he is literally the franchise
right now
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports